assault apologize in advance because I
am terrible at saying your character's
name the adjudicator the adjudicator I'm
wondering if you had any problems with
that at all no no it's me - okay thank
you thank you for that but it was a word
that I looked up I mean certainly you
know the word judge is within the word
adjudicator but certainly a word I
looked up to learn more about yeah
amazing so you guys are both new
characters in the John wick universe I'm
wondering if you remember the first
scene each of you shop well yeah the
first scene I shot we work together with
Laurence Fishburne
on the roof in Brooklyn that was both of
our first days yes
and could you talk about that what it
was like was it a immediate entry into
the universe that you get a little prep
did they tell you what to expect from
the universe it was it was a you know
trial by fire kind of gosh
I mean for myself you know it was
immediately a warm welcome into the John
wick family from not only everyone at
Lionsgate from Chad and Keanu who are
really you know leading the way on this
film and so I had already had
conversations with chat about the world
and about the character you know I'd
spoken to Keanu and so it really felt
like you know one of the things that
producers and directors are counting on
is that you're gonna show up prepared
and with having made choices but also
being flexible enough to take direction
and you know try new things and so trial
by fire but like fire that was like
exciting and charging and buoying I
think yeah I agree from you as well it
was it was fluid mm-hm
you know and having seen John wick 1 & 2
you kind of knew you were getting into
there's enough history there and then
talking with Chad and and you know
having having our characters on the page
you can kind of just step into it yeah
yeah I'm wondering how you found the
dynamic between your characters because
they both have quirks it's funny cuz
they could both be these he's very you
know just menacing characters but they
both have these odd quirks and they also
thing is interesting they both have very
different opinions of John wick himself
I'm wondering how you you guys navigated
that well I mean certainly one of the
fun things about working with mark is
the dynamic between 0 and the
adjudicator you know they certainly have
a long history together which we know
about and we discussed with Chad and
some of that comes out in the third film
and I think that it is because both 0
and the adjudicator enjoy what they do
that there is that element of sort of
quirkiness and humor I think one trope
is like a villain who is only a villain
you know and they are only menacing and
that's very one-dimensional and so I
think the opportunity to play
multi-dimensional villains so to speak
just added a layer of like fun to to
playing the characters which I think
on-screen is hopefully conveyed yeah and
I love the dynamic that the opening
scene we have together because it's
something for something you know you see
the adjudicator slides over the coin and
0 passes over some fish and you know did
you what I love is that zero is you know
he can handle all this you can handle
this and then the adjudicator it's not
that they ate the fish it's with how
they did it the confidence discount and
that makes zero go oh ok you know that
that opens it up there's a certain
there's a lot of risks there's already
respect but now who is this person and
what can they do you know is insane and
all the best ways possible
thank you much